hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute geht's ein richtig leckeres gebäck
mit rhabarber und zwar habe ich rabatt
sind knoten gebacken
das ist ein süßer hefeteig gefüllt mit
zimt zucker und butter und kleinen
rhabarber stückchen ich finde das
richtig genial weil darüber was soll ich
schmeckt und ich finde das passt einfach
super in dieses gebäck mit rein
ja ich möchte noch was sagen endlich mal
wieder warum endlich ein absoluter fan
eigentlich nett aber ich es überzeugt
ihn jedes mal im gegenteil machen wollt
weil er kein rhabarber fern wieder zeit
könnt ihr auch excel nehmen ihr könntet
eigentlich auch er zwar nehmen die
werden aber etwas weiter in der
konsistenz
ihr könnt auch heidi vernehmen also je
nachdem was ihr gerne möchte ware ist
mein fleisch genau und ich stelle sie
zuerst den hefeteig er und zeigt euch da
kurz zutaten für den hefeteig brauche
ich 500 gramm mehl 200 meter mills 180
gramm zucker hefe wasser etwas bei den
extrakt ein würfel hefe oder zwei
päckchen trockenhefe einen teelöffel
salz und 80 computer habe ich jetzt
bereits in einem topf vorhin etwas zu
lassen
ich nehme jetzt zuerst einmal die hilfe
und das wasser und die kommen jetzt
direkt in eine rührschüssel ihr könnt
den hefeteig natürlich auch mit der hand
verkneten
in der küchenmaschine geht es ein
bisschen schneller und einfacher da
kommt das waren arbeiter zu und auch der
zucker und das tue ich jetzt alles kurz
miteinander
jetzt gebe ich noch meinen extrakt mit
dazu und dann auch direkt das mädel da
gebe ich jetzt aber erstmal nur einen
teil mit ridinger verbindet sich besser
an die mädels
das sei und das salz und es wird jetzt
erst noch ein fakt
jetzt kommt nach und nach das restliche
mehl meter zu
und dann auch direkt die flüssige butter
und wenn ihr jetzt merkt der teig ist so
feucht dann könnt ihr gern noch etwas
hinzufügen aber lasst ihn lieber erst
mal ein paar minuten fehlten 70
denn dann wird er etwas fester und
vätern auch nicht mehr wenn der teig
sich vom strand löst dann ist er fertig
dann klebt dann nicht mehr
und jetzt brauche ich ihnen zu einer
kugel und lass ihn erstmal aufgehen
dafür gebe ich hier nicht zurück in die
schüssel mit etwas mehl und decken dann
noch ab und lassen für etwa 30 bis 60
minuten auch gehen bis sie verdoppelt
hat und in der zwischenzeit kann ich
schon mal die schulung vorbereitet
für die füllung brauche ich drei stangen
rhabarber drei esslöffel zucker 80 gramm
butter 50 g zucker um zwei teelöffel
sind ich nehme jetzt zuerst den
rhabarber und schelin
jetzt schneidet den rhabarber in kleine
würfel das mache ich jetzt im alligator
den rhabarber vermisse ich jetzt mit den
drei esslöffeln zucker dann lässt er
nämlich so ein bisschen flüssigkeit raus
und ich kann sie dann an der seite ist
ein paar menschen stehen lassen
in der zwischenzeit kann ich jetzt schon
mal die butter in einem topf geben und
ein bisschen erhitzen
also einfach damit bislang schmilzt und
jetzt kann ich dann auch gleich direkt
den hefeteig ausrollen
am besten heute den hefeteig jetzt auf
etwas mehl aus
es war zu einem großen rechteck
das recht ich bestreite ich jetzt mit
der flüssigen butter
jetzt muss ich noch kurz den zimt zucker
herstellen und staffel früher ich jetzt
zum zucker
und den streue ich jetzt da drauf
und da kommt jetzt die rhabarber stücke
drauf
jetzt fand ich dieses große stück einmal
fast bis zur hälfte und das andere dann
drüber also ich drittel das so ein
bisschen
dann wird dieser fest gedrückt und jetzt
schneidig hat die streifen zu recht
könnte das innere mit einem messer
machen oder mit einem teig rädchen ich
nehme da friert es bissig und schneidet
die streifen so etwa 2 cm dick
und diese teig streifen werden jetzt
gezwirbelt mit der hand und stand zu
knoten gelegt einmal noch mal langsam
also erst 25 und dann lege ich das zu
einem kreis und legt die äußere schlinge
darunter dann verschwindet der knoten
und ich kann so auf zack sind
jetzt wollen wir natürlich immer noch so
rhabarber stückchen ab die neben dir
einfach und streut sie noch obendrauf
das sieht dann später auch nach dem
backen richtig hübsch aus
und jetzt werden die rabatt noten im
vorgeheizten backofen bei 180 grad ober
unterhitze etwa 15 bis 20 minuten
gebacken
sie sollten schon goldbraun sein
die abag noten sind jetzt fertig
gebacken ich habe es auch ein bisschen
abkühlen lassen
jetzt könnt ihr sie so lassen wobei ich
sie hübscher und leckerer finde wenn ein
bisschen weißer schnee oben drauf kommt
der schnee sei nichts anderes als
puderzucker der aber nicht schmilzt der
bleibt immer schön trocken auf dem
gehweg liegen
und jetzt darf der morath direkt problem
des schützen sie sehen einfach so hübsch
aus die knoten das sieht aus wie gemalt
das ist es das dritte rezept rüdiger
weil weil ich kann ich zeig mal
anzuschauen wie toll das aussieht sieht
toll aus und ich mehr willst du bist
eigentlich kein rhabarber fan muss man
sagen berlin also ich mag aber wirklich
sehr gerne ich finde es so mit dieser
mit diesem soll wie ist euer liegendes
partner perfekt zu kuchen und gebäck
ja was soll ich sagen hätte ich
vergiftet ja weil ich habe jetzt sechs
mal hier noch lecker aber es ist ein
schatz zum akku sowie mira barrabravas
ist auch ich ja nur einmal im jahr muss
man doch ausnutzen glaube die gea group
ist auch gut so hallo
dann wird lecker schmecken und ja also
ich finds medial geradezu nachmittags
tee oder kaffee und ja ich mag ihre text
sowieso allgemein sehr gerne und das ist
halt richtig schön saftig und mit diesem
neuerlichen und damit dem puderzucker
mit dem film für mich ist wirklich das
perfekte rhabarber gebäck ich brauche
dringend erledigt jetzt gleich und falls
ihr dieses rezept nach machen wollt geht
auch cds - blog.de da steht es noch mal
ganz genau für euch und ich würde mich
freuen wenn er das rezept nach macht und
ich wünsche euch ganz viel spaß dabei
und wir sehen uns das nächste mal wieder
fangen wir mit der mehr als der meister
gemacht
nein
okay und ich recht ist für mein foto man
hat mich mal schmerzen
im anschluss werden